[Music]  blowing up this guy's blowing up over  here yeah what's going on oh well  actually you know what Nigerian prince  my brother just texted me and said that  I'm a there's a gif of me in the os10  messaging well I'm an OS 10 messaging  apparently me doing that is in the  messaging what is always sudden I don't  even know what that is it's the new it's  there's a there's an update for app for  iPhones and that's the operating system  you couldn't get some cash there are  chips in the messaging oh yeah that's  right I should be getting rich he said  it's me honey boo boo Donald Duck Judge  Judy etc well I'm really gangs back  together again  I'm officially I'm officially one of the  hind teeth of America  [Music]  you